so we hooked up that one night we had
sex and it was like it was really hot it
actually like happened in the shower on
the floor for like two hours like it was
awesome wow it sounds like it Emily
details her one night stand with Kobe
after meeting him in a nightclub in
China I love black guys so of course I
found the only black guy in China and
she explains how their love story went
from something spontaneous and wild I
thought Kobe was just gonna be a really
fun one night stand to something so
precious
[Music]
yet extremely challenging it's been two
years since I've seen Kobe we'll get
into what makes Emily and Kobe the
couple to watch and you'll get a sneak
peek of my exclusive interview with them
yeah we're having a watch party I'm
really nervous so and then to have like
our entire family in the same room
watching it like my grandma and aunts
and uncles and like you know us making
out it's a little much so uh it'll be no
it'll be fun plus I definitely can't
provide for the Kardashian lifestyle
that miona has been looking up to I have
my diamond earrings came out I'll give
you a quick rundown of the other couples
that grabbed my attention and my first
impression of their relationships now
you're coming to my home which will be
our home it's excited it's sad there's
many emotions and in some way just
because some Latino
is very dramatic
looks like it's going to be a solid
season let's get into it
hey 90 day fans fam it's Malicia season
9 of 90 Day Fiance is here and you know
whenever new couples come in it takes a
minute to warm up to them and to
actually care but this group feels
different it seems as if this time
around casting prioritized genuine
couples instead of the most bizarre
storylines despite the 28-year age
difference it honestly feels like
mahogany is my soul mate no Shades have
been in Mahogany just trying to make a
point here girl how you gonna say no
Shea and then shade them out that lady
all I'm saying is a season's cast is
refreshing if you watch the premiere
episode give me your feedback what did
you think my name's Emily I'm 29 years
old and I live in Salina Kansas in the
meantime let's dive into Kobe and
Emily's love story
I think they may become fan favorites I
feel the same way girl alright Emily
grew up in a small town in Kansas it's
quiet you know it's quaint there's not a
lot to do and when she got to college
she let loose
I definitely wanted to you know party
and not study and I was like oh you know
what's a degree I'd rather go hang out
with my friends and have a good time
Emily then randomly decided to move to
Thailand for a month
and then China for summer do 90 day cast
members ever make you feel like you need
to be more adventurous would you jump up
I know sometimes their Adventure leads
to Wild outcomes but I can't help but
admire someone who was bold enough to
live life on the edge like that and
seriously just do whatever it is they
want nothing really holds me back and I
just do what I want to do I was in Xi'an
China and I got the opportunity to teach
English there for two months I
definitely wasn't looking to meet
someone and have a serious relationship
and I think I had about like two and a
half weeks left and one night I met Kobe
and it changed her life forever I have a
feeling we're not in Kansas anymore
this is me in person okay here is Kobe
he's a 34 year old international
underwear model what an international
underwear bundle you know obviously
that's a perk too and he's from Cameroon
the night I met Kobe we're actually
having a girls night Emily says she
looked over her shoulder and saw this
guy in all white dancing immediately she
was attracted to him his arms were huge
and muscular and I was like whoa this
guy's really sexy I've got to get to
know him somehow someway Emily found her
type in a nightclub in China I love
black guys so of course I found the only
black guy in China
what are the odds my first like real
boyfriend was a black guy her love for
black guys is something we talked about
during our chat like our my high school
we had like I think two black guys like
not that many at all
um I don't know I was just always
attracted to him you know I like
you're so hot so like in high school you
know once I started dating like my first
boyfriend yeah he was a black guy and it
was just
what I go for you can hear the rest of
that conversation plus more in my
interview with Emily and Kobe
subscribe to entertainment tonight's
YouTube channel so you don't miss it you
can also catch it on etonline.com
alright let's get into Emily detailing
their one night stand which sparked the
flame that's still burning so we hooked
up that one night we had sex and it was
like it was really hot it actually like
happened in the shower on the floor for
like two hours like it was awesome Emily
says she didn't expect it to go any
further than that passionate night but
to her surprise things got serious fast
he was just so sweet and just like a
genuinely nice guy I knew it was
somebody who I wanted to be with I was
like wow I really think I love you like
even so quick and we just didn't want to
leave each other yeah he's the nicest
guy I've ever been with like it still
blows my mind that I met him in China at
a bar Kobe ended up proposing to Emily
in China
and four weeks into their engagement she
found out she was pregnant
Jesus
I was really fearful about his reaction
but Toby was like ecstatic I always knew
I wanted to be a mom even in second
grade I told my teacher I did not need
to learn math because I was going to be
a stay-at-home mom and take care of all
of my kids I've always admired a girl
who fights for what she wants you know
fun fact before we go any further during
my interview with Kobe and Emily I found
out that these two didn't even apply to
be on the show a friend who was aware of
their story and what they were going
through applied for them according to
Emily she and Kobe knew nothing about 90
Day Fiance since everything had been
moving so fast I wanted Kobe to come to
America and meet my family before making
wedding plans so we applied for a
visiting visa and while we were waiting
on that Kobe went back to Cameroon and I
went back to Salina and moved in with my
parents when it comes to Emily's parents
here's how they reacted when she
returned to America from China it's
expecting a baby oh your ass is grass
they were already nervous enough to let
me go to China and here I come back with
like a very expensive souvenir forever
Emily says her parents were shocked and
her mom was really upset because she
didn't know how all this would work out
I mean let's face it your track record
hasn't been great Emily goes on to open
up about her past relationships
and how her choice of men play into her
parents fear about Kobe in my early 20s
I definitely didn't have a very good
self-worth so I just like hook up with
guys I went for like the bad boys I mean
two of my exes are incarcerated
I wonder for what well I mean you know
it's one thing if it were only you but
it's not only you yeah you got you know
you have to consider the baby and what's
best for him a week before Emily's due
date they found out Kobe's visitor Visa
was denied so he wasn't able to be at
their son cobin's birth
it was really emotional when my son was
born
you're crying but you're happy but
you're crying because his dad's not here
so after copen was born Kobe and I
decided to file for the K1 Visa so our
family could be together well covet came
and put a pause on that dream
now Emily hasn't seen Kobe in two years
and Kobe has never met his son in person
it's like it's just sad that
you know his dad's not here to like
change the first diaper you know to like
throw him the ball or like teach him
French you know like it's just been
Mommy Mommy so
it's definitely hard you know I could
only imagine and then there's the
pressure to not only make sure the baby
knows he has a dad say hi Daddy
but to keep Kobe in the loop with
everything so he doesn't feel worse
about missing out oh
I feel bad that's a lot of
responsibility on a new mom
see being adventurous can be great but
it can also come with outcomes that are
least desirable uh I'm just gonna stay
over here also I want to give props to
Emily I don't know if it's just me but
the fact that this one and a half year
old who has never met his dad in person
reacts this way when he sees him on
video
foreign
says a lot it's pretty impressive
he's like
a wild man but
excited to see his daddy oh my gosh well
now after all the waiting there is light
at the end of the tunnel for Kobe and
Emily we learn in the premiere episode
that his K-1 Visa has been approved and
he will be in America in a matter of
days
although this is exciting understandably
it also has Emily nervous when Kobe and
I were in China it was definitely
honeymoon phased you know we were able
to go to the clubs to the bars and like
have a good time
and now like I'm not a partier anymore
I've changed a lot physically when he
met me I was super fit went to the gym
every day now I have a mom bot and we
have a son and I don't know if the
chemistry's still there I don't know if
he's gonna find me attractive I really
don't know what he's gonna think of me
when he gets to America
so much I love you baby and I can't wait
to see you guys oh how cute
when Kobe gets to America they will be
staying with Emily's parents
we don't know Kobe at all uh The Limited
exposure we've had to him has been on
the phone and so the judgment's still
out there as to whether he's a good guy
or not but Emily is our wildest child
you know her track record's not that
good so
we're hoping Kobe is the guy that uh is
the is the real deal well Emily
her is clearly the real deal
six months and Emily working as a nanny
doesn't cover all their bills her dad
has decided to take care of her Kobe and
Cobin for the time being until Kobe can
get on his feet that's so nice but he
has one condition but one thing's for
sure you better not get pregnant okay
okay
all right okay yeah okay we haven't seen
the guy in two years you know I mean if
you got I mean I
have my mom
doubt seeps in even more for Emily's
parents when Emily says Kobe opened up a
cafe in Cameroon three months ago even
while he knew he was coming to America
sounds like this guy doesn't really know
how to make money and it doesn't have a
really good business sense about him and
that's that's a big problem yeah he
doesn't have a good track record on the
business no and I'm I'm a little leery
about this whole thing he's going to be
here for 90 days I'll be able to tell
right away whether he's bullshney or not
he's gonna have to prove to me that he
can support you and especially Cobin and
himself in America without me being
involved okay
we'll see what happens
I'm looking forward to seeing Kobe
transition from Cameroon to Kansas and
how he's going to interact with Emily's
parents
according to her they were all very real
on the show it is 100 not script
and what you see
our life
quickly
introduction to the other 90 day couples
who made strong Impressions during the
premiere
my name is Cara I'm 29 years old and I
live in Charlottesville Virginia Cara is
so cute she's smart she's full of
personality and she's currently a
balloon maker I make big balloon
garlands
I like being able to help people
celebrate fun times she's engaged to
Guillermo who is 23 from Venezuela they
met while she was working another job in
the Dominican Republic I was literally
just sitting at a table working on my
computer with my colleague and Miss
waiter strolled up to our table and said
ladies tequila time and I was like damn
he's cute fast forward he pops the
question after living together for about
eight months
we decided to go ahead and move forward
with the K-1 Visa so that we could start
our lives in the United States
Cara's job in the Dominican Republic
fell through so she decided to head back
to the U.S and due to covid she wasn't
able to see Guillermo for over a year
but now she's returning to the Dr to
escort him to his new home
I'm so happy I'm so happy
happy happy yeah beyond words no words
it feel a little bit sad too I'm leaving
friends but I will have new friends so
it's exciting it's sad there's many
emotions and in some way just because
some Latino it's very dramatic
these two are obviously madly in love
the passion and the chemistry is there
look at them they can't keep their hands
off each other
but in the back of Kara's head she does
have a concern about their six-year age
difference which we'll start to see play
out my name is jabri I'm 28 years old
and I live in Rapid City South Dakota
and finally jabri and miona jabri is a
musician in a band he's been living in
Los Angeles but since covet hit he moved
back home to save money for his fiance
miona to be able to move to the U.S
makeup artist from Niche Serbia and
she's 23 years old it's your birthday
it's your birthday me on a birthday do
it get the right way miona's a small
sexy Fireball she's got a temper she
tells it how it is and this is corny but
the first time I saw me on in person I
had the butterflies in my stomach and
you know I started feeling you know a
bunch of emotions jabri and miona met
while his band was touring in Serbia
only problem here is I think miona is
more concerned about living this Los
Angeles lifestyle than building a life
with jabri
I know you don't want to be here in
South Dakota but you can consider us pop
saving funds and and having a marriage
here
I want to leave third degree I
recall and leave like a 50 year old I
definitely can't provide for the
Kardashian lifestyle that miona has been
looking up to the Kardashians are making
it hard for men out here
my diamond earring came off in the ocean
and it's gone okay there's people that
are dying
back lip is Iconic these two seem cute
though hopefully as we get to know them
more we'll see that that relationship
just isn't based on The Superficial I
don't know about that as always time
will tell next week miona arrives in
South Dakota and jabri has the red
carpet ready come here princess this is
in a 90 Day Fiance this is your red
carpet let me do a little spin let me
get a little photo missed all right 90
day fans fam I think we're off to a good
start with this season once again let me
know what you think and make sure you
stick with ET because we are covering it
all I will see you next time
foreign